[Music]  oh i  don't wanna ride on your shoulders and  put you in the hospital  i  just wanna roll away boulders all they  said it wasn't possible  don't you know that i'm an irrepressible  optimist working with a fatal flaw  running in the streets like feral cats  will be hot to mystic and me and razor  paul  tell us what you think you saw what you  think you saw tell us what you think you  saw  make a picture  make it snappy  make a picture  don't look so happy  all the scalloped  [Music]  faces smiling faces  [Music]  man  [Music]  [Music]  oh i  don't want to hear what's impossible  with the shepherd's tone  and if we're ever gonna get out of this  hospital you will never sleep alone  listen to the cries of the wounded  metropolis then it's in some tent hooks  listen to the cries  [Music]  make it  make a picture  [Music]  don't look so happy  all the skyline faces  [Music]  the braces  [Music]  will never sleep alone  [Applause]